avec l'arrivée des beaux jours les
grands espaces verts en milieu urbain
accueille de plus en plus de visiteurs
des visiteurs qui souvent sans trop s'en
rende compte pertur des écosystèmes qui
sont déjà bien fragile
j'en fasse très savamment soir soit fait
leur lit par caen ville sont vraiment
des espaces précieux là qu'il faut
savoir protéger ce sont des havres de
paix pour nous évidemment on y va pour
se rafraîchir
pour changer d'air ça règle le climat
également mais il faut savoir se sont
aussi bien sûr des refuges pour la
biodiversité
or certains de nos comportements qui en
apparence peuvent en l'air tout est fait
anodins peuvent être lourds de
conséquences pour vous donner une idée
de l'impact de cette cohabitation
parfois difficile entre l'humain et la
nature dans ces espaces urbains suffit
de savoir que par exemple sur le mont
royal à montréal on a noté au début des
années 90 la disparition de la
grenouille des bois du crapaud
d'amérique également un déclin dans les
espèces d'oiseaux nicheurs comme les
grives lebrument également une déclin
dans la fleur de certains sous bois tout
ça parce que vous savez où vous vie
qu'il faut marcher entre autres dans les
sentiers dans les sentiers qui sont
balisés tout ça parce que le territoire
ne doit pas être fragmenté quand il ya
un morcellement du territoire
quand vous partez à droite à gauche pour
aller voir un arbre une plante
il peut paraître anodin mais vous savez
il suffit d'à peine 50 personnes qui
passent par ce petit corridart pour que
ça devienne vraiment un chemin qui petit
à petit deviendra un vrai sentiers et
quand on mord c'est le territoire comme
ça on envahit l'espace vital de
plusieurs espèces animales la flore
également et ça c'est pas bon pour le
maintien de la biodiversité
il faut aussi ne pas oublier de se
retenir un peu et n'a pas donné toutes
sortes de choses à manger aux animaux ça
c'est difficile je vous le concède ça
peut sembler vraiment dû coliques de
nourrir un certain
ni aux ratons laveurs mais c'est pas une
bonne idée tout d'abord parce que ces
animaux peuvent être des vecteurs de
maladies mais également parce que ça
peut modifier leur comportement les
rendre agressif
ils vont devenir également dépendants de
vous pour se nourrir c'est pas une bonne
chose et en plus dans le cas des ratons
laveurs parfois on leur donne à manger
la malbouffe car est loin des guimauves
des frites des chiefs et on a vue sur le
parc du mont-royal donc sont à mon temps
dit [ __ ] laveur édenté et aux baisses
et ratons laveurs et dans télé obs bon
faut aussi garder nos animaux en les
animaux domestiques en car leurs deux
chiens peut être gentil bien élevé il
revient quand on l'appelle mais ce n'est
pas une bonne idée de le laisser aller
boire dans les temps à les côtoyer les
animaux parce que c'est un prédateur est
aussi même si les vacciner même s'il est
en bonne santé
votre animal de compagnie peut être un
vecteur de maladies transmettre des
maladies on a décimé la population de
renards sont le mont royal à montréal à
cause de la gale possiblement transmise
par un chien donc un mode d'emploi assez
simple finalement pour préserver nos
parts tout à fait simple alors on met
ses déchets dans la poubelle ça votre
foi mais on ne laisse pas de trace les
anglais disent leave no trace donc la
proche sans tracé vraiment ça la clé du
succès merci beaucoup changé